Welcome back.
By the end of this lesson, you will be
prepared with the workflow that will
make it easy for
you to optimize your images so
that they take up as little bandwidth
as possible while still looking great.
You'll be thinking about
image quality and size.
And with images on the web,
it all comes down to size, but
what does that actually mean?
Here's a question for you.
Can you spot the differences
between these three images?
To be honest,
I can't tell the difference with my eye.
These three look the same to me.
For this quiz, check out
the site in the instructor notes.
Then use DevTools to work out
the difference between the three images.
Are the differences caused
by compression level,
display resolution, the natural
resolution, or the file type?
Check all that apply.